المترجم: Aya AlAjjan
المدقّق: Hamzeh Koumakli
يقول الرافعي: "ما ذلّت لغة شعبٍ إلا ذلّ،
ولا انحطت، إلا كان أمره في ذهابٍ وإدبار
ومن هذا، يفرض الأجنبي المستعمر
لغته فرضاً على الأمة المستعمرة،
ويشعرهم عظمته فيها،
ويستلحقهم من ناحيتها،
فيحكم عليهم أحكاماً ثلاثة في عملٍ واحد:
أما الأول، فحبس لغتهم في لغته سجناً مؤبدا
وأما الثاني فالحكم
على ماضيهم بالقتل محواً ونسيانا
وأما الثالث، فتقييد مستقبلهم
في الأغلال التي يصنعها لهم
فأمرهم من بعدها لأمره"
(تصفيق)
بدأت القصة منذ 8 سنين
كنت طالباً جامعياً في السنة الثالثة،
وطُلِب مني بحثٌ عن مرضٍ معين
لجأت إلى صديقٍ أكبر مني
وأعطاني مقالاتٍ وأبحاثاً
وقال لي: "إذا أردت التوسع
فلتبحث على الإنترنت
لكن أنصحك ألا تبحث
باللغة العربية لأنك لن تجد شيئاً
ابحث باللغة الإنكليزية"
لماذا بالإنكليزية؟
أيعقل ألا أجد شيئاً؟
فهو مرضٌ قديم، ومن المؤكد
وجود مقالاتٍ عريبة عنه
كما يوجد مثيلها في اللغة الإنكليزية!
عدت إلى المنزل وأنا أبحث
وبالفعل لم أجد شيئاً سوى بعض
المقالات الموزعة في المنتديات
اضطررت أن أبحث
بالإنكليزية ثم أترجمها وأقدمها
في اليوم التالي، تابعت التفكير بالموضوع
لربما لا توجد معلومات كثيرة باللغة العربية
عن هذا المرض بالذات
يجب أن أبحث من جديد
بحثت في غوغل ووجدت أن
النتائج الأولى للبحث العلمي عليه
من موقع يدعى ويكيبيديا
دخلت إليه، وشعرت أني وجدت ما أريد
ويكيبيديا موقعٌ يحوي حوالي 295 لغة
يوجد في صفحته الرئيسية
حوالي 10 لغات أساسية
ومن بينها اللغة العربية
مما يعني أنهم يعترفون باللغة العربية
كلغة أساسية وعالمية
نظرتُ إلى الأرقام المكتوبة أسفل أية لغة
فوجدت باللغة العربية
ما يقارب 500 ألف مقالة
باللغة الإنكليزية، يوجد 5437962
- لا تتأكدوا من دقة الرقم
هنا فأنا لا أحفظه -
(تصفيق)
قلت لنفسي: "لا يهم الكمُّ كثيراً
لعل النوعية أهم"
إذا دخلت على أيٍّ من المقالات،
تجد في إحداها 40 صفحةً بالإنكليزية
إنما في المقابل باللغة العربية،
فيها ما يقارب 3 إلى 4 أسطر
حسناً، حصل خير ..
لم لا أبدأ العمل بما يخص هذا الموضوع؟
وبالفعل، مسكت آلتي الحاسبة
وأخذت أحسب ما يلزمني من الوقت
كي أترجم هذه المقالات
بما أني أحب الكتابة على الحاسوب
لأستعيض عن سوء خطي
وأحب اللغة العربية وأعرف الإنكليزية جيداً
دخلت وبدأتُ أحسب بآلتي الحاسبة
وجدت أني إذا أردت ترجمة كل هذه المقالات
لا أحتاج أكثر من 900 عام
900 عاماً!
بغض النظر
عن أي حفيدٍ سأملكه حينها
لكن 5 ملايين مقالة لن تبقى
ذاتها، قد تصبح 200 مليوناً
وفي النهاية نحن نملك 5 ملايين مقالةً عربية
قلت لنفسي مالي ومالهذا العناء!
هل أفهم بالاقتصاد والهندسة
والرياضيات وما غيرها؟
سأعمل بما أراه ذا ارتباطٍ بتخصصي
سأعمل بما له علاقة مع الطب والصيدلة
مسكت الحاسبة مجدداً ووجدت
أني أحتاج حوالي 80 عاماً
80 عاماً خلف الحاسوب طوال النهار
مع احتمال الإصابة بآلامٍ في الظهر
أو الاحتياج للنظارة كما أفعل الآن
حاولت أن أفكر مجدداً قليلاً بالموضوع
إذن لمَ ذلك؟
لم لا يوجد اهتمامٌ باللغة العربية؟
ولمَ صدقنا أن الإنكليزية هي اللغة الأساسية
التي تُفرض على كل العلوم؟
إذا عدنا بالموضوع قليلاً إلى الوراء
وجدت أنه في فترةٍ من الزمن
من المرحلة العباسية
انتشرت الحركة التي لها
علاقة بالترجمة كثيراً
في ذلك الزمن، ترجم العرب
كل ما وصل إلى أيديهم
مقالات، أبحاث، أساطير، روايات .. أي شيء
بغض النظر عن محتواها صحيحاً كان أم خاطئاً،
لكنهم في النهاية ترجموها
ترجموها كي يتمكنوا
من مناقشتها، كي يبنوا عليها
أو كي ينقدوها.
قد يكون هذا جزءاً
من مشكلتنا التي نعيشها الآن
اليوم، أي شخصٍ في المرحلة
الجامعية يرغب بإجراء بحثٍ ما
فهو بحاجةٍ لأن يبحث عن مصادر للمعلومات
لكنها غير متوفرة
إلا باللغة الإنكليزية للأسف
وهو هنا بحاجةٍ لتعلم لغةٍ ثانية
وسيستغرق ذلك منه وقتاً كثيراً
وبغض النظر عن ذلك كله، لا يستطيع الإنسان
أن يعي الكلام المكتوب بلغة ثانية
تماماً كما يعيه بلغته الأم
حتى لو عمل أي شخصٍ بهذا المجال
في الآخر فإن المقالات
والأبحاث التي يتم نشرها،
يتم نشرها بالأصل باللغة الإنكليزية
ويتم الحفاظ عليها بتلك اللغة
ولا نجد لها مقابلاً بالعربية.
بصراحة نحن بحاجة لأن نعمل
على نقل هذا المخزون العلمي العالمي
من اللغة الإنكليزية إلى اللغات الأخرى
تماماً كما ينقله الألمانيون إلى الألمانية
وكما ينقله اليابانيون إلى اليابانية
وكما -
هل يستطيع أحدكم قراءة ما يكتب على الشاشة؟
حسناً، أيستطيع أحدكم فهم هذه اللغة؟
ألم تمرّ معكم؟
هذه لغة سيبوانو
لغة سيبوانو هي لغةٌ يحكي بها
حوالي عشرين مليون شخصاً
ويعيشون بأقصى شرق القارة في الفيليبين
ومع ذلك، يوجد على موقع
ويكيبديا مثلاً وبهذه اللغة
4 ملايين مقالة، وهي ثاني أقوى
لغة في النشر بعد اللغة الإنكليزية
إذن أيعقل أننا لا نملك الإمكانيات والقدرة
حتى ندعم نشر المحتوى العربي؟
قلت لنفسي "يجب أن أبدأ من ذاتي
ويجب أن أتحرك كي أدعم هذا الموضوع"
لم لا نبدأ بهذه الحركة؟
وبالفعل تواصلت مع أصدقائي
في الجامعة ومجموعات الفيسبوك
وبدأنا نعمل بما يتعلق بموضوع الترجمة
وحين بدأنا بالفعل، واجهتنا مشكلة أساسية
في إحدى المجموعات التي تضم
سوريين ومصريين ومغربيين
حصل خلافٌ على بعض المصطلحات
كيف نترجم (بكتيريا)؟
هل تبقى (بكتيريا) أم نترجمها (جراثيم)؟
أم (كائنات حية)؟
وكيف نترجم مثلاً (metabolism)؟
استقلاب أم تمثيل حيوي أم ماذا؟
أيعقل ألا تستطيع اللغة العربية
أن تساعدنا على أن نبني مصطلحات جديدة
باللغة العربية؟
عندما احتاج الإنكليز لبناء مصطلحات جديدة
لم تساعدهم لغتهم في الواقع
ولجؤوا حينها إلى أمرين:
الأمر الأول، لجؤوا إلى اللغة اللاتينية
لأنها أقدر على النحت
والاشتقاق من اللغة العربية
والأمر الثاني، أنهم لجؤوا
إلى شيءٍ له علاقة بالاختصارات
كي يستخرجوا كلمات جديدة
بحيث تكون أسهل للتداول
ما رأيكم إذا قلت لكم اليوم
أنه يوجد مرض في العالم
أصيب به 35 مليون شخصاً
ويموت بسببه 2 مليون شخصاً سنوياً
وأحببت أن أسمي هذا المرض (داء المساعدات)؟
أو أن أسمي الفيروس الذي يسببه (ف.ن.م.ب)؟
مثلاً
قد يكون الموضوع غريباً بالنسبة لنا قليلاً
ولعل بعضنا يضحك
لا أعرف إن كان الإنكليز يضحكون الآن أم لا
لكنهم إلى اليوم يستخدمون كلمة (إيدز)
والتي هي اختصار للأحرف الأولى
من مرض متلازمة عوز المناعة المكتسب
وكلمة (إيدز) في الاستخدام اليومي
العادي تعني (مساعدات)
لم يجدوا بصراحة أي مشكلة
في أن يستخدموا الكلمة
التي رأوا لها معنىً معيناً
بمجالٍ آخر حتى تعبر عن شيءٍ آخر
ونحن نجد هذا الشيء ضعيفاً
أو لا يعجبنا
قد نكون بحاجةٍ إلى أن نؤمن أكثر
بأن الإمكانيات الموجودة
في اللغة التي نحكي بها
تجعلها واحدةً من أقوى اللغات في العالم
وهنا نحن بحاجة في الواقع
إلى مرجعية معتمدة -
بالمناسبة، في فرنسا
يُدعى مرض الإيدز (سيدا)
وذلك لأن ترتيب الكلمات في لغتهم يختلف
نحن بحاجةٍ إلى مرجعية معتمدة
ترجع إلى المترجمين أو الباحثين
بما يخص المصطلحات باللغة العربية
وبصراحة تم إنشاء ما يدعى
بالمعجم الطبي الموحد
ولا أعرف ما إذا كان يوجد
شيءٌ مشابه بمجالات أخرى
كالاقتصاد أو إلى ما هنالك
لكنه لم يأخذ حقه بالانتشار
ربما لأننا لا نؤمن بعد بأنه يمكن
استخدام هذه الكلمات العربية
نحن بحاجةٍ لدعم من أجل نشر
هذه المعلومات والمقالات
سواءً كانت بحثية جديدة
أو مترجمة من لغات أخرى
ولا نستخف بضرورة أن يتواجد
هذا المحتوى العلمي
لأنه سيوفر الجهد والوقت
على الكثير من الباحثين
نحن بحاجةٍ إلى جهود
قد تقوم بها جمعياتٌ أو مؤسسات
لكنها يجب أن تبدأ في بدايتها من أنفسنا
لأن ..
الجهود التي نبذلها ستخفف
كثيراً من هذه الفجوة الموجودة
في النهاية، أحب أن أذكركم
إذا أحب أحدكم أن يترجم هذه المقالات لوحده
بما أنه لوحده فهو يحتاج
على الأقل إلى 80 عاماً
وقد ذهب منهم ربع ساعة
خلال حضور هذا النقاش.
(تصفيق)